[Music]
the universe is a very big place
there are trillions of galaxies each one
home to millions of stars and an
unimaginable number of planets so where
is everybody one of the most basic
philosophical questions is are we alone
are we the only ones looking out and
thinking what is all this is it all just
for us or do we get to share it with
anyone I mean that's about as
fundamental a question as you get what
are the odds of life existing somewhere
else we just don't have a good insight
how probable life is anywhere at the
universe life could possibly be forming
everywhere we we don't quite know
there's a lot about life that we don't
understand all we know is that it
happened at least once but beyond this
one little planet we don't know whether
or not it happened anywhere else
the universe is an unfriendly place
planets with lava oceans circle too
close to their stars pulsars blaze with
deadly gamma rays and x-rays black holes
consume everything in their path
temperatures plummets close to absolute
zero it may seem impossible for life to
survive in such hostile environments but
here on earth life exists against the
odds in some very strange places life is
actually permeated every part of our
planet there are places where you're
like how did you even get there
at first glance a beautiful lake might
seem like a good place for life but
California's Salton Sea is no paradise
the toxic salt waters are killer
surrounded by scorched desert and
volcanic geothermal fields
it's a deadly environment
one of the last places on earth you'd
expect to find life would be in boiling
mud fence start to hear these vents
because there's gas and there's water
and mud slurry that's coming out right
here so these are active volcanoes but
life is resilient finding a home even
here inside volcanic vents in the
California desert we're in the middle of
a really hot desert and as the mud comes
up it's coming up hot and gets kind of
acid and yet there can be microbes in
environments like this happily thriving
away this is an environment that is
actually conducive to life even though I
think it might not be almost every inch
of the Earth's surface is teeming with
microscopic life-forms the thing about
life on Earth is that it's exists in so
many different environments under such
harsh extreme conditions it's like it
hangs on no matter what you throw at it
very dry high pressure very hot even in
high radiation environments which would
kill a human within seconds
[Music]
life even survives being bombed with
asteroids and meteorites
we have a wonderful indirect example of
just how tenacious life is and that's
the fact that it survived the late heavy
bombardment the late heavy bombardment
was a violence assault on young earth
where life had just gotten the foothold
experts think around four billion years
ago asteroids comets and space debris
rained down on the inner solar system
this rocky barrage would have melted
parts of the Earth's crust and boiled
away oceans it was a violent time called
the Hadean period the Hadean named off
to hades named off the underworld off to
hell it was a brutally unpleasant place
to be whispering its own in its sound
surface and this intense cycle of hot
volcanism
if life on earth overcame these hellish
conditions then perhaps life can survive
anywhere I think if it can happen on
earth I think it can happen on other
planets I think life finds a way and I
think we need to go looking for it the
question is what exactly are we looking
for
what is life you know that seems like a
simple question but it's not that easy
to answer life is incredibly hard to
define right it's sort of like you know
it when you see it but how do you write
down the rules every time we think we
have a grasp there's this new form that
comes about and completely questions
that entire definition as a joke in
astrobiology if you ask 200 scientists
for a definition of life you'll get 200
different answers life can be as
intricate as us humans or as simple as
single-celled organisms like bacteria
but there are some things all life-forms
do in broad terms life consumes things
it breathes it eats it excretes it grows
it reproduces it's complex
life has transformed the earth in all
sorts of ways but life is still just an
accident
life as I see it it's just a chemical
reaction but it's the most important and
special chemical reaction in the
universe if life is just a product of
chemistry then what are the odds of it's
starting anywhere in the universe one
thing we know about chemistry is that
given the right conditions the same
chemical reaction will reliably occur
it's like a game of chance for life to
win the conditions need to be just right
but to figure out the odds we need to
understand what those conditions are and
how common they are so it comes down to
a numbers game it's about statistics and
probabilities and likelihoods it's like
having to roll a 6 for each condition
for life
but how many sixes would you need how
many precise conditions does life
require to get going you might have a
hundred dice roll them all get all sixes
only then do their life you could need
hundreds or hundreds of thousands of
dice
we just don't know we honestly have no
clue how common or rare life is in the
universe we don't know how life
originated here on earth where we kind
of understand the conditions there are a
lot of different ways life could have
started his life rare is life common we
don't know where it lands
putting odds on life existing is a waste
of time until we understand it better
and maybe our answers don't lie here on
earth
one way to crack this problem is to go
looking for life elsewhere if we can
find other examples of life we can
immediately begin to put a quantitative
answer to how probable it is for life to
happen anyway and the best place to look
for life might be in our own backyard
Mars if life can start here that maybe
life could conquer the universe
[Music]